the Marvel Cinematic Universe has been
going strong since 2008 but as of Phase
5 its Story covers thousands of years
need to catch up on the latest
developments uh let's just go through
the whole thing uh where to start um
if you really want to know where things
started in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you have to go all the way back to
before the Big Bang no really before the
beginning of the universe before even
the creation of the six singularities
that caused the universe to explode into
existence they were the celestials
beings of infinite cosmic power the
celestials led by erisham the judge
created the original planets stars and
life forms of the infant Universe
following the Big Bang realizing they
need help to expand the universe and
create more life the first celestials
seed planets with embryonic celestials
these new Gods would be born once
sentient life on each planet Rose to a
critical juncture allowing for the
emergence of a new Celestial and
resulting in the destruction of that
world to assist in this process the
celestials genetically engineered
deviant monsters to wipe out the apex
predators of each World encouraging
sentient life to develop and multiply
unfortunately the celestials
miscalculated the deviants did their job
so well they started hunting down and
killing all life forms preventing
emergences to keep them in check the
celestials created the eternals
synthetic life forms sent to different
worlds across the cosmos to kill the
deviants and protect the planet's life
forms regarded as gods and superheroes
by the populace the eternals are
unknowingly preparing the planets for
their destruction following each
emergence the eternal's memories are
wiped so they could be reused on
different worlds meanwhile other
interesting things are happening
throughout the Universe the six
singularities that created the cosmos
became the Infinity Stones objects that
controlled fundamental forces like time
space and reality itself they were then
scattered Across the Universe popping up
here and there and awaiting the eventual
arrival of a giant golden oven mitt that
would be used by a purple sociopath to
kill off half the universe that of
course was billions of years ago but
it's not the only thing to happen in
those long eons millions of years before
we get to the present day MCU ego the
living planet comes into existence gains
Cosmic awareness and seeds thousands of
Worlds with his Essence in an attempt to
create another Celestial being like
himself but though he may in fact be a
god-like figure in the end he's still
essentially just a selfish deadly Dad no
wonder Peter has issues well of course I
have issues
my freaking father while ego considers
most of his early attempts at Offspring
failures and kills them out of
disappointment he does keep at least one
of his kids around the insect-like woman
mantis whose empathic abilities help ego
sleep
as far as heroes and villains of Earth
are concerned the MCU doesn't start with
Tony Stark getting kidnapped in 2008
Carol Danvers being taken to Hala in the
90s or even with Steve Rogers
volunteering for the super soldier
program in the 40s the actual beginning
happened in 5000 BC when 10 Immortal
eternals Cersei Icarus ajac Kingo Sprite
fastos Makari thina jurig and Gilgamesh
arrived on Earth to take out the
deviants on our planet for thousands of
years the eternals protected emerging
humankind largely through epic super
battles with giant monsters by 1521 the
eternals finally managed to defeat all
the deviants on Earth or so they think
lacking any real Direction now that
their main reason for coming to the
planet is gone they scatter and get jobs
as teachers Bollywood film stars and
South American cult leaders since the
celestials have instructed the eternals
not to interfere in humanity unless
deviants were involved other god-like
beings get the chance to descend onto
Earth and have their time to shine these
include the asgardians vastly powerful
alien beings who visit our planet many
times and give rise to Norse mythology
still the most exciting stuff those guys
were up to happens off-world in the
realm of Asgard this mythological time
scale begins Millennia ago as we find
out in Thor the Dark World when the dark
elf malekith the accursed Lays Siege to
Asgard using a weapon known as The Ether
actually an infinity stone that controls
reality to revert the universe to a
state of Perpetual darkness malekith is
thought off by Bohr the father of Odin
in 2988 BC or vanquishes malikin which
turns out to be a temporary solution
causing the dark elves to go into a
state of hibernation for the next 5 000
years or then buries The Ether on a
distant world
while we don't know exactly when it
happens the next chronological event
that we see from our characters is
Odin's conquest of the nine Realms
alongside his first child hella goddess
of death during this era the magic
Warhammer mjolnir is forged in the heart
of a Dying star and used by hella thanks
to her bloodthirsty ruthlessness and
ambition Odin turns against her and in
the battle that follows hella Slaughters
the valkyrior the soul-surviving
valkyrie flees from Asgard spending the
next few thousand years drunk and
depressed eventually she winds up on
zakar a cosmic garbage dump that an
immortal being called the Grand Master
builds into an Interstellar gladiatorial
Arena hella is then imprisoned in
another dimension by Odin who covers up
all traces of her existence
sometime after that but still far enough
back that people were writing about it
in the 13th century Odin and Friga have
a son Thor shortly thereafter Odin slays
the frost Giant lalphie and adopts his
son Loki as his own not too long after
this during their youth Loki turns into
a snake because he knows Thor loves
snakes and then tries to stab him in one
Universe he manages to succeed what was
your Nexus event your majesty
we killed Paul also millions of years
before the present day two meteors made
out of the super Metal vibranium strike
the Earth One meteor lands in Africa
drastically affecting the surrounding
area much much later this area becomes
the country of wakanda when a warrior
Shaman receives a vision from the
goddess Bast ingests a vibranium altered
heart-shaped herb that grants him great
powers and founds a dynasty of warrior
Kings known as the Black Panthers the
wakandans become secretive and
isolationist remaining unconquered
throughout history and using the
vibranium to create fantastic technology
away from the eyes of the outside world
the second meteor crashes into the
Atlantic ocean near the Yucatan it
mutates the undersea plant life in
viewing many species with mutagenic
properties in 1571 a Yucatan Mayan tribe
dying of the smallpox virus introduced
by the Spanish colonizers came across
one of these vibranium altered plants
which mutated them into a
water-breathing people the tribe
migrated to the Puerto Rico trench and
built the underwater Kingdom of telecon
using the rich deposits of vibranium
Beneath the Sea one telecano woman is
pregnant when the plant mutates her
causing her to give birth to a mutant
child
born with winged feet superhuman
strength and a very long lifespan the
child develops a hatred for surface
dwellers when he sees a plantation owner
abuse his Mayan slaves after the telecon
boy orders his people to burn down the
plantation a dying priest calls the
young mutant El Nino cinamore the child
without love which the boy adopts as his
new name Neymar Namor rules over his
kingdom for centuries and becomes known
as kukul Khan or The Feathered Serpent
God by his people
over five thousand years before the
present day a faction of the
militaristic alien race called the cree
arrives on Earth and conducts
experiments on humans creating the early
Inhumans one of these Inhumans known as
Hive drives the cree from the earth and
establishes a cult of personality that
regards him as a God after being
banished his followers work to restore
him while destabilizing Earth's Society
over time the society becomes the
terrorist organization Hydra moving to
just about a thousand years before the
present day the warlord Shu winwu makes
a fantastic discovery of his own when he
comes across 10 otherworldly rings that
Grant him immortality and the strength
of a god using the Rings to establish
his ten Rings criminal organization
winwoo conquers kingdoms and topple's
governments amassing an incredible power
structure that influences the direction
of the world
over in Eastern Europe the Demonic
entities tone writes a set of spells and
a structure at the top of Mount
wundergore
the original text is then copied into a
more portable book The darkhold that
falls into the hands of several dark
magic users including the witch Morgan
lafay elsewhere a Celtic Woman trains in
the Mystic Arts to protect the Earth
against magical threats after drawing
power from the dark dimension she
becomes functionally Immortal and takes
on the name the Ancient One
in 1693 the witch Agatha Harkness
escapes being burned at the stake by her
mother and a bunch of other witches who
aren't happy with her practice of dark
magic she drains their life energies and
gets her hands on the dark hold before
disappearing to get into all sorts of
trouble before she pops up again in the
present day jumping ahead to 1942 a Nazi
officer known as Johann Schmidt
experiments on himself with an early
version of Dr Abraham erskine's super
soldier serum gaining both a physically
perfect body and a decidedly redder
complexion now calling himself The Red
Skull he takes charge of a splinter
group called a Hydra with the discovery
of one of the Infinity Stones in the
form of the Tesseract he creates a
technologically advanced Army of his own
that same year Steve Rogers volunteers
for the Strategic scientific reserves
attempt at creating a super soldier
using a technique created by Dr Erskine
the project Works giving Steve the body
of a hunky Chris Evans after the
experiment Erskine is assassinated and
his research is lost rather than risking
their only super Soldier by sending him
to fight in the war the SSR gives Steve
the code name Captain America and uses
him primarily as a spokesman to sell war
bonds and Uso shows set to an extremely
catchy song Eventually Steve goes AWOL
to rescue his best friend Bucky Barnes
and becomes an active soldier in the war
working with tech genius industrialist
Howard Stark falling in love with SSR
agent Peggy Carter and leading a strike
team called the Howling Commandos on one
of their missions Bucky falls from a
train into a ravine seemingly to his
death however Bucky is actually taken
into custody by the Soviet Army given
cybernetic enhancements and brainwashed
into becoming a Super assassin codenamed
Winter Soldier after attempting to use
the Tesseract The Red Skull is sucked
into a wormhole becoming the second
person in Captain America the First
Avenger to survive an apparent death in
reality he lines up on the distant
planet vormir serving as a sort of
spectral Guardian for the Soul Stone as
for Steve he crashes a bomber jet into
the Arctic to keep Hydra from destroying
New York he is also presumed dead but he
survives Frozen in suspended animation
for the next 66 years geez doesn't
anyone who dies in this movie actually
die are you ready to follow Captain
America into the jaws of death hell no
while things are pretty quiet for the
MCU between 1945 and 1995. there are a
few notable exceptions Peggy Carter
continues to work for the SSR first in
New York in 1946 and then in Los Angeles
alongside Howard Stark in 1947. although
Hydra is believed to have been destroyed
it actually secretly infiltrates the U.S
government quietly influencing
historical events around this time the
Soviet Union produces the first
graduates of its brutal Red Room
facility where orphaned girls are
trained as spies and assassins codenamed
black widows during the 1950s Korean War
veteran Isaiah Bradley and several other
African-American soldiers are
unknowingly subjected to a new version
of the super soldier serum Isaiah gains
superhuman abilities and is sent on
secret missions including one where he
battles a still brainwashed Bucky Barnes
and learns his identity Isaiah
subsequently goes AWOL to save his
fellow Soldier Years From A POW Camp in
the aftermath all the soldiers except
Isaiah die from the serum's side effects
Isaiah is imprisoned for 30 years so CIA
and Hydra scientists can experiment on
him and try to replicate the serum in
his blood eventually a nurse takes pity
on Isaiah and has him declared dead
allowing Isaiah to return to Baltimore
Maryland and live with his family
sometime after this presumably around
1948 or 49 Steve Rogers travels back in
time from 2023 to reunite with Peggy she
continues to work in Military
Intelligence for the next few decades
with Stark whose defense contracts turn
Stark Industries into the world's
leading arms manufacturer by 1970 both
of them are working out of SSR
headquarters at Camp Lehigh along with a
few other notable figures Arnhem Zola
who worked with the Red Skull back in
the 40s is stationed here and although
his body dies in the 70s his brain is
transferred into a computer data bank
that continues hydra's in filtration of
the government also Hank Pym is working
here assisted by Bill Foster in his
experiments with the size changing pen
particles that will allow him and his
wife Janet Van Dyne to become the
original Ant-Man and wasp between the
70s and the 90s several small but key
events happened throughout the MCU in
1974 Howard Stark launches the Stark
Expo displaying the city of the future
powered by a clean energy Arc Reactor
that's about the size of a house for
some reason he also hides the structure
of a new element in the arrangement of
the buildings which is the kind of
science it pays to not think too hard
about congratulations
you have created new
one in 1980 ego comes to Earth winning
the heart of Meredith quill nine months
later their son Peter Quill is born in
1987 Janet Van Dyne is lost in the
quantum realm after she and Hank Pym
attempt to stop a rogue Soviet missile
targeting the United States in 1988
Meredith quill dies from brain cancer
intentionally caused by ego leaving her
son a mixtape of classic rock favorites
Peter is then abducted by a band of
outer space Outlaws called the ravagers
their leader yandu then raises Peter as
a son to keep up appearances yondu
treats Peter harshly in front of the
ravagers but shows the boy great
affection privately even giving Peter a
pair of laser pistols as a Christmas
gift and teaching him valuable survival
skills in 1987 Janet Van Dyne and Hank
Pym attempt to stop a rogue Soviet
missile targeting the United States to
destroy the missile Janet intentionally
shuts off her size-changing regulator
and shrinks through the missile's
molecules she continues shrinking right
into the subatomic Quantum realm
devastating both her husband and her
young daughter hope him spends the next
several years studying the quantum realm
unintentionally estranging himself from
his daughter by 1989 Pym resigns from
the SSR now renamed the Strategic
Homeland intervention enforcement and
Logistics Division after finding out
that they intend to use his pen
particles to create weapons also that
year Air Force Captain Carol Danvers who
uses the call sign Avenger during her
flight volunteers for a test flight of a
light speed engine created by scientist
Wendy Lawson Lawson turns out to be one
of the cree a militaristic alien race
constantly at war with the
shape-shifting Scrolls and her engine is
powered by the Tesseract when they're
shot down Carol's body is overloaded
with the tesseract's energy giving her
incredible powers and also wiping her
memory a Cree soldier named Yan Rog
abducts her and takes her back to the
cree Homeworld of Allah where she has
made the belief that she's actually a
Cree named veers fighting alongside them
as a member of the cree Star Wars
while all of this is happening on Earth
things continue to develop in space
Thanos an incredibly powerful alien from
the Planet Titan who's obsessed with
balance begins to seek out the Infinity
Stones along the way he lays ways to
half of the population of entire planets
occasionally taking young survivors and
training them as soldiers assuming that
most of the more humanoid characters are
the same age as the people portraying
them then his two most notable adoptions
happen in the late 80s or early 90s
Gamora is taken in as a young girl after
Thanos kills half of the population of
her home planet throughout her childhood
Thanos pits her against her adopted
sister nebula every time they Spar
Gomorrah wins and Thanos systematically
replaces pieces of nebula's body with
cybernetic Parts in order to make her a
more efficient killer this creates a lot
of resentment and nebula not only
against Thanos but also toward Gamora
which will greatly affect their later
relationship
elsewhere in the Galaxy a geneticist
known as the high evolutionary starts
orgocorp an Intergalactic company that
produces bioengineered products to
benefit all life however orgocorp is
actually a front to fund the high
evolutionary's illegal genetic
experiments and allow him to create his
vision of a perfect Society his
experiments result in The Sovereign a
highly Advanced golden skinned race and
the Human animals intelligent humanoid
animals while many of the high
evolutionaries Creations consider him a
God the high evolutionary sees them as
disposable experiments and regularly
destroys entire planets when the
subjects don't live up to his
expectations one of the high
evolutionaries experiments is subject
89p13 a cybernetically enhanced raccoon
with a genius intellect who renames
himself rocket believing the high
evolutionary will take him and his
fellow experiments Lila thiefs and floor
to live in peace on a new planet rocket
help helps him with his experiments
however when high evolutionary kills his
friends a devastated rocket mauls the
High evolutionaries face and escapes he
becomes a bounty hunter and adopts a
bitter cynical attitude to help him deal
with his trauma meanwhile in the quantum
realm a stranded Janet Van Dyne comes
across another Castaway an exiled
variant of Nathaniel Richards named Kang
the Conqueror initially believing Kang
to be benevolent Janet helps him rebuild
his damaged multiversal power core so
they can escape the realm however when
she realizes what a monster Kang really
is she enlarges the power core so it
can't be used trapping them both in
their subatomic prison unfortunately
Kang is still able to charge his armor
and use its power to create the city of
Axia the capital of his fascist Empire
feeling responsible Janet joins a
resistance movement against Kang
in 1991 the Soviet government sends the
Winter Soldier to assassinate Howard and
Maria's start this will have massive
ramifications later on but the immediate
effect is that their brilliant slacker
son Tony Stark is left in charge of
Stark Industries along with Obadiah
stain as CEO they continue to
manufacture weapons using Tony's
increasingly deadly designs selling them
to all sides of virtually every global
conflict with Obadiah in particular
making a profit from Secret arms deals
with terrorist groups in 1992 king
t'chaka of wakanda goes to Oakland
California to investigate arms deals
involving stolen vibranium the culprit
is his brother in jobu who is killed in
the altercation in jobu's son Eric is a
witness to the whole thing and grows up
craving Revenge he joins the Navy Seals
and becomes part of a CIA Black Ops unit
killing hundreds of people around the
world around the same time nine-year-old
Matt Murdock is blinded by a drum of
toxic waste while trying to save a man
from being hit by a truck the chemicals
heighten his other senses to superhuman
levels allowing him to move and fight
better than before after his father is
killed by Mobsters an orphaned mat is
mentored by the blind Warrior stick who
trains him to use his senses As Weapons
stick later abandons the boy but Matt
continues training and studying
eventually becoming both A Gifted
fighter and law student meanwhile
Russian super soldier Alexi shostakov
and black widow weapons designer Molina
vostikov go deep undercover in Ohio
posing as an All-American family with
their so-called daughters seven-year-old
Natasha Romanoff and three-year-old
Elena Bulova while Alexia Molina worked
to steal a shield or actually Hydra
project focused on Free Will and mind
control Natasha and Yelena experience
some semblance of a normal childhood by
1995 however the mission is complete and
the family flees to Q Cuba however once
they arrive they are split apart and
Natasha and Yelena returned to the Red
Room where they continue their black
widow training slash torture sessions
also in 1995 Carol Danvers still without
her memories of Earth returns to her
home planet after escaping from the
Scrolls she teams up with Shield agents
Nick Fury and Phil Coulson to stop the
skrulls from invading Earth only to
learn that they're not actually the bad
guys instead it's decree that are the
problem with yanrog and Ronan the
Accuser enroute in search of the
Infinity Stones that will end their war
of Conquest once and for all Carol
taking the name Captain Marvel fights
them off and saves a bunch of skrull
refugees in the process an alien cat
scratches Nick Fury's left eye blinding
it and causing him to sport a
fashionable eye patch before she
Journeys back into space to Aid the
skrulls Carol gives Fury a pager the can
Summoner in case of a dire emergency
inspire hired by Carol and her original
Call Sign Fury lays the groundwork for
The Avengers Initiative a program
designed to create a team of
super-powered Heroes to deal with
large-scale threats like alien invasions
in 1996 winwoo having used his 10 Rings
organization to secretly conquer or
influence practically everything on
Earth turns his attention to the
mystical realm of tala after finding a
magical forest near the village entrance
he meets and falls in love with the
village Guardian Ying Li the two marry
and have two children Xiang Chi and
xiaoling for a time when will reforms
but when his wife is killed by his
Rivals he decides to recreate the tin
rings and train his son Chung Chi to be
a living weapon around the same time in
Chicago Illinois a young Mark Spector
and his little brother Randall are
exploring a cave when it suddenly floods
drowning Randall Mark's mother Wendy
blames him for the accident and a
traumatized Mark manifests the alternate
personality of of Stephen Grant to help
him cope with his mother's verbal and
physical abuse in 1999 Tony Stark meets
bioengineers Maya Henson and Aldrich
Killian at a conference in Burns
Switzerland he's very rude to Aldrich
who remembers that as a soar point for
about 14 years throughout all this Hydra
continues its secret infiltration of
shield and all levels of the United
States government
all that brings us to 2008 and Iron Man
the movie that launched the MCU almost
everything from here on plays out in
chronological order in the years the
movies were actually released almost in
2008 Tony Stark is demonstrating his
newest weapons in the Middle East when
he's kidnapped by a terrorist
organization called the ten rings in
what will eventually be revealed as a
plot by stain to get Tony out of the
picture while he's imprisoned the
terrorists force him and another captive
Dr Ho yinson who was also at that
fateful 1999 convention in Burn not that
Tony noticed to make weapons for them
instead Tony is able to recreate a
miniaturized version of his father's Arc
Reactor using it to stabilize a piece of
shrapnel that's lodged near his heart
the reactor also Powers the Iron Man a
suit of weaponized armor built from
scrap which allows Tony to escape after
Jensen's death Pony historic was able to
build this in a cave
with a box of scraps
he returns to America eats a
cheeseburger refines his design and
wipes out the 10 Rings the ones in the
Middle East at least in a brutally
effective display of the Iron Man's
weapons he also defeats stain who
attempts to kill Tony and create his own
massive suit of powered armor Tony then
publicly Reveals His identity as Iron
Man causing Nick Fury to approach him
about the Avengers Initiative around the
same time as Tony's capture Dr Bruce
Banner whose seven phds apparently
include physics and biological
engineering is working on recreating the
super soldier program instead of
erskine's Vita Rays he uses gamma
radiation testing it out himself and
turning himself into a rampaging green
monstrous Hulk whenever he gets angry
after the Hulk inadvertently injures
Banner's girlfriend Betty Ross he
attempts to go underground but returns
to America in search of a cure for his
condition he winds up dealing with a
scientist named Samuel Stearns who wants
to recreate the Hulk and a soldier
called Emile Blonsky who turns himself
into a similarly hulking monster called
the Abomination ultimately the Hulk
defeats the Abomination who sent to
prison and Stearns absorbs some of
Banner's blood causing his brain to
mutate Banner then goes back into hiding
and starts learning how to control his
Transformations also around this time
Shield agent Clint Barton AKA Hawkeye is
tasked with finding and eliminating
Natasha Romanov the Black Widow Barton
tracks down Natasha to her safe house in
Budapest but feels Natasha wants out of
the Red Room so he lets her live Shield
decides to let Natasha defect to their
side but requires her to kill her
overseer General drakoff first Natasha
and rig a five-story building with bombs
and lure the red room's Mastermind into
the Kill Zone but drakov's young
daughter Antonia also gets caught in the
explosion while disturbed by the
additional red in her Ledger Natasha
nevertheless begins working for shield
six months after revealing his identity
publicly Tony Stark is called to testify
before Congress because they are
justifiably concerned about a private
citizen building a suit of armor that
can vaporize a tank to create their own
version they turn to rival weapons
manufacturer Justin Hammer after Tony's
friend Colonel James Rhodes delivers a
prototype Iron Man suit hammer and
Russian scientist Ivan vanco reverse
engineer them into an army of drones
Stark also gets a new personal assistant
an undercover Natasha going by the name
Natalie I want one no Stark and Rhodes
equipped with his own militarized suit
of armor codenamed War Machine defeat
vanco and Hammer over the 10 Rings
compound a now 14 year old chongqi has
become the Master of Kung Fu having been
taught every possible way to kill a man
over the last seven years assigned to
assassinate the man responsible for his
mother's murder Xiang Chi completes his
mission but is badly traumatized
unwilling to return to his father Zhang
Chi cleverly adopts the name Sean and
starts going to high school in San
Francisco there he meets his best friend
Katie a skilled driver meanwhile a now
adult Mark Spector leaves home to join
the United States Marine Corps but gets
discharged because of his dissociative
identity disorder with few options Mark
becomes a mercenary and works for his
former commanding officer Raul Bushman
in addition to doing some jobs for the
CIA Mark is ordered by Bushman to
execute some archaeologists at an
Egyptian dig site instead Mark tries to
save the scientists but gets shot dying
Specter is approached by the Egyptian
god of the Moon konshu who offers to
save Specter if he will become his
Avatar and punish evildoers on Earth
seeing himself as little more than a
killer thanks to his childhood abuse
Specter agrees and is transformed into
these Supernatural vigilante Moon Knight
while all this is happening on Earth
there's other stuff going on in the
golden realm of Asgard Loki tricks Thor
into antagonizing the frost Giants of
yotenheim against Odin's orders as a
consequence Odin Exiles Thor to Earth
and enchants's Hammer mjolnir so that
only someone worthy of Thor's power can
lift it it lands in New Mexico where
Agent Coulson discovers it after a bunch
of hicks try to yank it out of the
ground with pickup trucks Shield
constructs a temporary facility around
it Thor eventually proves him
self-worthy regains his hammer and stops
Loki from staging a coup in Asgard in
2011 a team of Russian oil drillers
discovers the crashed Hydra plane in the
Arctic and alerts Shield Captain America
is thought out and revived and after
realizing he's in the 21st century he
joins up with Nick Fury's Avengers
Initiative it turns out he was just in
time
in 2012 Loki last seen a drift in space
after his failed coup in Asgard is
enlisted by Thanos to recover the
Tesseract from Earth with his recent
brief visit to the planet being seen by
The Mad Titan as relevant employment
experience
in exchange Thanos gives him control of
the chitari a massive Army of Hive
minded destroyers and a scepter
containing the Mind Stone another of the
Infinity Stones using these weapons Loki
lets himself be captured by Shield
incites a riot and stabs poor Phil
Coulson in the back but don't worry he
gets better the ensuing Ruckus provides
the superheroes with a reason to come
together the result is the Battle of New
York in which the Avengers Captain
America Iron Man Thor Black Widow Hulk
and Hawkeye are gathered for the first
time as a team the good guys win after
Loki is smashed against the ground five
or six times but the battle is not
without its consequences unlike in the
real world where it's pretty nice these
days the mcu's version of Hell's Kitchen
takes a lot of damage and winds up being
a center of corruption and graft as it's
rebuilt this Injustice leads blind
lawyer Matt Murdoch to take on the
identity of Daredevil to fight against
criminal Kingpin Wilson Fisk and
eventually elite team up with other
super powered street-level crime
Fighters Jessica Jones Luke Cage Iron
Fist and kinda sword of the Punisher on
Netflix
the Reconstruction of New York is mostly
handled by the newly formed Department
of damage control we take over the
lucrative contract and leave
construction Foreman Adrian tombs in
bitter and in possession of advanced
alien technology tombs builds his own
underground criminal Enterprise selling
reverse engineered Qatari weapons on the
black market while the Battle of New
York comes with its fair share of trauma
it also leaves some people inspired
after seeing Clint Barton unknowingly
saving her life while battling aliens
with a bow and arrow ten-year-old Kate
Bishop decides to take up archery and
learn martial arts in an attempt to
protect her family against future
threats she turns out to be a gifted if
extremely Reckless Prodigy who often
damages public property with their trick
shots in 2013 Tony Stark in particular
is overwhelmed by the concept of his
Universe suddenly expanding to include
Gods aliens and other unknowable Cosmic
forces he deals with post-traumatic
stress which on unfortunately coincides
with the return of Aldrich Killian
Killian has been experimenting with Maya
Hansen's regenerative extremist
treatment which has the unfortunate
tendency to cause its subjects to
explode to cover his operations Killian
appropriates win-woo's 10 rings and
creates a fictional terrorist based on
win-woo called The Mandarin hiring an
actor named Trevor Slattery to play him
in threatening videos the plot is
uncovered and stopped by Tony and Rhodey
I wouldn't go in there for 20 minutes
in the aftermath Killian is killed by
Pepper Potts and Slattery gets sent to
federal prison where he's later abducted
by the real tin rings for impersonating
Wynwood although win-woo is intent on
killing this strange man who named
himself after a chicken dish he has a
change of heart after seeing how good
Slattery is at performing Shakespeare
and decides to make him his Jester
around this time Phil Coulson resurfaces
and begins recruiting some additional
members into his own Agents of Shield
they have their own Adventures including
many involving the Inhumans and Ghost
Rider but like the good secret agents
they are a lot of this flies beneath the
radar of most major MCU events oh also
malikith comes back and Thor fights him
and Loki becomes the latest in a long
line of Presumed deaths that actually
aren't he stashes Odin in a retirement
home in New York and then takes his
identity ruling over Asgard and putting
on critically acclaimed plays I'm sorry
about that thing with the Tesseract I
just couldn't help myself I know I'm a
trickster
in 2014 hydra's decades-long plot to
infiltrate and take over America is
finally discovered by Captain America
and Black Widow who also learned that
the Winter Soldier is a brainwashed
Bucky Barnes while cap fights to restore
his best friend's Memories the Hydra
plot is exposed and in the aftermath
Shield collapses leaving The Avengers
without the oversight and support of the
larger organization that power vacuum
leads directly to Tony Stark and Bruce
Banner attempting to create an
artificial intelligence that would help
protect the world Unfortunately they
goofed that plan up big time instead
creating a genocidal robot named Ultron
who winds up destroying an entire city
resulting in the breakup of the country
sokovia immediately after the battle the
Hulk hijacks a quinjet and blasts off to
space eventually landing on zakar hoping
for an ally against Ultron Tony and
Bruce combined the Mind Stone a
synthesized body created by Ultron and
Tony's onboard AI Jarvis into a much
more heroic AI called The Vision also
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver two
definitely not mutants join the team
Speedster Quicksilver immediately dies
partly from bullets but mostly because
Disney and fox were having a problem
figuring out the characters film rights
the destruction in sokovia also kills
the family of helmet Zemo who then
dedicates his life to Revenge while all
that's going on Peter Quill is out in
space on a job to steal a valuable orb
which unbeknownst to him contains the
infinity stone known as the Power Stone
that puts him in the sights of both
Rhone and the accuser who's been looking
for another infinity stone since 1995
and Thanos who sends Gamora after him
quill and Gamora wind up running across
Drax a very literal Warrior whose family
was killed by Thanos rocket the
cybernetically enhanced raccoon and
Groot a tree after being in prison
together the five of them stage a
jailbreak defeat Ronan in a dance-off
recover the power stone with the help of
the real power which is friendship
during the adventure group dies leaving
behind a baby Groot sapling and the
group christens themselves the Guardians
of the Galaxy they turn the power Stone
over to the Nova Corps a bunch of space
cops on the planet xandar shortly
thereafter Thanos attacks xandar and
recovers it for himself
in 2015 an electrical engineer named
Scott Lang gets out of prison and
stumbles onto Hank pym's old size
changing equipment under the guidance of
Pym and his daughter hope Lang becomes
the second Ant-Man and helps to keep the
pen particles from falling into the
hands of evil arms dealer Darren cross
when Darren Dons his own size-changing
suit and becomes the villainous
Yellowjackets lango's subatomic and
damages Yellow Jackets suit so badly
that the bad guy seemingly shrinks into
Oblivion actually cross Journeys to the
quantum realm where he's found by Kang
and rebuilt as Modoc the mechanized
organism designed only for killing more
importantly it's likely somewhere around
this time that a kid named Peter Parker
is bitten by a radioactive spider tries
to capitalize on his powers by becoming
famous as Spider-Man and fails to stop a
robber that later kills his Uncle Ben
none of this is actually covered in the
MCU but you might have seen five other
movies about it the following year sees
helmet zemo's plan to destroy the
Avengers reach its fruition as the world
responds to the destruction of sokovia
by trying to install new governmental
oversight Over The Avengers Zemo
furthers a wedge between Captain America
and Iron Man by revealing that Bucky was
the one who killed Tony Stark's parents
he also frames Bucky for the
assassination of king tachaka of wakanda
leaving the King's son t'challa to take
over leadership of the country not to
mention the identity and powers of the
Black Panther the end result of all of
this is that the Avengers break up the
ones loyal to cap go underground and
t'challa refuses to give Zemo the death
he desires Bucky also gets safe refuge
and treatment in wakanda after t'challa
realizes they were all being manipulated
by Zemo fleeing the U.S after the rest
of Cap's team is in prison Natasha
Romanov spends some time in Norway
watching James Bond films unfortunately
her vacation is cut short when she's
attacked by Taskmaster an assassin who
could mimic any fighting style later she
discovers Taskmaster is the brainwashed
daughter of a still alive General
drakoff who has restarted a crueler
version of the Red Room that brainwashes
new black widows and robs them of free
will one of those black widows turns out
to be Natasha's sister Yelena freed of
her programming by another Widow Elena
sends the brainwashing antidote to
Natasha drawing her into the fight
together Elena and Natasha work to
reunite with their former parents Alexi
and Molina and really kill Drake off
this time although the dysfunctional
Deep Cover family has more than its
share of issues they managed to pull
together and take down the Red Room in
the end Yelena gets to work liberating
black widows around the world while
Natasha goes to break her other family
The Avengers out of jail
while all this is going on Dr Steven
strange who lost the fine motor control
in his hands after a car accident seeks
out the ancient one and trains to become
a master of the Mystic Arts he stops an
invasion by dormammu a demonic force
from the dark dimension by using the
time Stone to trap dormammu in a Time
Loop where the entity kills strange over
and over again until the cosmic villain
gets annoyed enough to leave Earth alone
meanwhile the Guardians of the Galaxy
encounter ego and Peter Quill's
half-sister mantis ego reveals that
Peter is his son and the heir to his
power but when he tries to manipulate
him into Conquering the entire galaxy
mantis teams up with the Guardians to
Kill The Living Planet the Guardians
also incur the Wrath Of The Sovereign
after rocket steals some of their
batteries for absolutely no reason in
retaliation their leader Aisha decides
to create a more powerful Sovereign
named Adam to go after the Guardians
in the absence of the Avengers Tony
Stark begins to Mentor Peter Parker as
Spider-Man Peter tries to deal with the
evil arms dealer known as the vulture
AKA Adrian tombs who turns out to be his
homecoming date's dad the vulture is
defeated arrested and sent to prison but
not before he and several of Peter's
classmates figure out Spider-Man's real
identity also Tony Stark finally
proposes to Pepper Potts lest you think
Peter is the only super powered teenager
in the MCU over in New Orleans teenagers
Tandy Bowen and Tyrone Johnson acquire
powers of light and darkness and become
the Vigilantes Cloak and Dagger
meanwhile on the west coast privileged
teenager Alex Wilder and his friends
learn their parents are all super
villains who control a powerful criminal
organization called The Pride the kids
go on the Run learn many of them have
superpowers or connections to Advanced
Technology and even run afoul of
dangerous artifacts like the dark hold
sadly it looks like Peter won't be
meeting any of these young Heroes as
their worlds are only slightly connected
to the MCU meanwhile Mark Spector
marries Leila elfule the daughter of one
of the archaeologists he failed to save
the night he became Moon Knight the two
go on many adventures together but when
Specter learns konshu may use Layla as
his new Avatar he sends divorce papers
to her hoping to create some distance
between them and keep her safe in Asgard
Thor returns from two years of looking
for Infinity Stones in various Realms
only to discover Loki's been posing as
Odin this entire time when Thor and Loki
find the real Odin he's at the end of
his life and his death allows hella to
escape her Millennia of imprisonment she
destroys mjolnir blasts the two brothers
into space and takes over Asgard Thor
winds up on sakhar where he recruits
Hulk and Valkyrie for a mission to
overthrow hella which goes about as well
as it can for a plan that ends with the
complete destruction of Asgard via fire
Giant in wakanda t'challa's rule is
challenged by his cousin Eric kilmonger
who teams up with evil arms dealer
Ulysses claw and then betrays him in
order to gain favor with wakandans who
know claw as a vibranium Smuggler Eric
nearly kills t'challa usurps his
position as the Black Panther and
destroys all of wakanda's heart-shaped
herbs to secure his power base
after being presumed dead t'challa
returns and aided by Nakia Okoye and
shuri regains control of his country
later he secretly fathers a son with
Nakia who decides to raise her child in
Haiti away from The Black Panther's
enemies
after six years of waiting around Thanos
decides to personally seek out the
Infinity Stones and the results are
devastating he kills Loki sacrifices his
daughter Gamora to get the Soul Stone
and nearly obliterates the last
surviving asgardians as he goes after
the remaining Stones things get so
desperate that the whole Avengers crew
need to get back together to sort it out
except Hawkeye and Ant-Man who are under
house arrest for violating the sokovia
Accords they don't do so well despite
fighting on two fronts with one small
team in space and a massive force on
Earth Thanos gathers the stones snaps
his fingers and kills half the life
forms in the universe dissolving them
into dust before he dissolves Nick Fury
uses the space pager to alert Captain
Marvel that earth needs her help a month
later Captain Marvel and the surviving
Avengers track Thanos down in space only
to find out that he's destroyed the
stones and with them any chance of
bringing back the dead half of the
universe Thor beheads Thanos and the
Avengers return home Ant-Man and his
friends miss all of these events due to
their involvement in a relatively
self-contained Heist movie alongside
Scott Lang in the new wasp Pope Van Dyne
Hank Pym suits up and explores the
quantum realm in order to save the
original wasp Janet meanwhile the team
fends off repeated attacks from a
mysterious super-powered being known as
ghost later Lang explores the quantum
realm just as thanos's snap turns Hank
Pym and both Van Dyne women into dust
trapping Ant-Man in the subatomic realm
while he's there five years go by during
which the heroes deal with the horrific
trauma in various ways notably Tony
Stark and Pepper Potts have a daughter
named Morgan Banner merges his brain
with the Hulk and Thor becomes an
overweight gamer after helping to found
new Asgard in Norway
Hawkeye loses his entire family in the
snap causing him to go Rogue he adopts a
new hairstyle and anti-hero identity as
the merciless Ronin who hunts down and
ruthlessly kills criminals around the
world one of these criminals is William
Lopez the father of fighting Prodigy
Maya after seeing her dad die Maya
swears Vengeance on Ronin not knowing
that her dad's boss Kingpin wanted
William dead after Ant-Man returns from
the quantum realm where for him only a
few hours have passed the heroes realize
that the solution to the problem is of
course time travel with the help of Iron
Man rocket a reformed nebula and the now
smart Hulk the heroes travel back to
various key points in the timeline
including 1970 2012 and 2014 to gather
up the Infinity Stones of those eras
along with Monier Circa 2013.
unfortunately the Avengers also
inadvertently bring the Thanos of 2014
forward to 2023 along with all of his
minions this includes an alternate
Gamora with no memory of her time with
the Guardians fortunately the Hulk uses
a rebuilt Infinity Gauntlet to wish
everyone back to life and virtually
every hero in the entire MCU takes
Thanos on at once the final blow is
dealt by Iron Man who dies on the
battlefield after gathering for a
funeral Steve Rogers hops into the time
stream to return everything to where it
should be returning after living a full
life with Peggy Carter in an alternate
pass to bequeath his shield to Sam
Wilson naming him the new Captain
America
outside of the mainstream MCU the
version of Loki that the Avengers freed
from an alternate 2012 in Avengers end
game ends up in the Gobi desert where he
immediately begins fulfilling his
glorious purpose by trying to conquer
the world again instead he gets picked
up by the time variance Authority or TVA
a Time police force tasked with hunting
down Rogue variants like Loki and
destroying alternate timelines before
they can Branch out too far from their
sacred timeline Loki gets paired with
Mobius a sympathetic TVA agent who
recruits the trickster God into the
agency to help find their latest Target
another Loki variant this isn't about
you
this variant turns out to be a female
version of Loki called Sylvie who
restarts the Multiverse allowing a bunch
of Rogue timelines to emerge from
history Loki teams up with selfie and
discovers the TVA is made up of variance
forcibly recruited into the organization
to prune Rogue timelines and prevent
really evil versions of the tva's
mysterious leader another variant of
Kang from destroying everything while
offered a chance to let this deception
persist Sylvie instead murders The
Mastermind letting the Multiverse run
wild while this may lead to the
destruction of reality it makes one
Cosmic being's life more interesting the
Godlike voyeur The Watcher observes
realities in which Peggy Carter receives
the super soldier syrup Dr Strange
destroys his universe and Thor becomes a
party animal ultimately The Watcher is
forced to evolve from Observer to doer
when a variant Ultron threatens to
destroy all sentient life in the
Multiverse assembling his own Guardians
of the Multiverse team The Watcher
manipulates events so the alternate
realities can continue to co-exist
sometime after the Multiverse was
recreated a young girl named America
Chavez develops the ability to travel
through alternate realities unable to
control her power she accidentally sends
her parents to an unknown world before
slipping through multiple parallel
universes herself along the way she
makes friends usually with variants of
Doctor Strange
in the mainstream MCU the effects of
Hulk's reverse snap are being felt on
both the cosmic and street level people
like Elena Bulova and Monica Rambo snap
back to existence only to discover the
five years have passed and their loved
ones are now gone re-establishing their
lives proves difficult since different
people live in their homes and billions
are still legally dead while support
networks form entire nations are also
forcing out recent immigrants due to the
sudden rise in population believing life
was better during the blip when half of
all life was gone some people react to
these changes violently Anarchist Carly
Morgan though forms a terrorist group
the flag Smashers to attack governments
threatening her One World Vision And
even augments her team with a new
version of the super soldier serum this
puts her in the sights of Sam Wilson who
rejects Steve Rogers request that he
become the new Captain America after
working with Bucky Barnes and seeing how
Steve's Legacy can be tarnished by
unworthy successors like the dangerous
unhinged John Walker Sam takes on the
mantle of Captain America and stops the
flag Smashers taking advantage of the
global chaos and recent superpowered
debuts a mysterious woman named
Valentina Allegra de Fontaine begins
recruiting enhanced individuals
including Elena biloba and John Walker
for an unknown project meanwhile Peggy
Carter's niece Sharon a former Shield
agent goes Rogue and begins selling U.S
government weapons to terrorists as the
power broker of the island nation of
madrapore Sam also meets an elderly
Isaiah Bradley and learns his history
although Isaiah is skeptical about the
idea of a black Captain America Sam
arranges for an exhibit of Isaiah's
service to be displayed at the
Smithsonian so everyone will know about
the United States's first
African-American super soldier the
sudden rise in sentient life on Earth
also jump starts the emergence which
threatens to destroy the entire planet
when a new Celestial is born alerted by
the cosmic event and a few remaining
deviants the eternals reunite where
before they have always stood by and
allowed planets to be destroyed a few
now have enough love for Humanity to try
and save the Earth Cersei draws enough
power from her teammates to Halt the
birth of the celestial Tiamat and the
celestial erisham uses the eternal's
memories to determine if Earth should be
spared
in Europe Peter Parker attempts to have
a vacation free of Spider-Man
unfortunately this becomes impossible
when Nick Fury actually the
shape-shifting scroll Talos who is
covering for Fury while he's on vacation
in space recruits Spider-Man to help
Mysterio a man claiming to be from an
alternate universe to save the world
from dangerous Elemental beings except
it's all a lie Mysterio is just Quentin
Beck a disgruntled ex-stark employee who
uses Peter to get his hands on a pair of
Stark Tech sunglasses that can control
an army of weaponized drones Spider-Man
gets the drop on Mysterio's Illusions to
keep him from killing thousands of
people but in a final Act of spite
Mysterio exposes Peter's secret identity
to the world meanwhile former assassin
turned car valet Xiang Chi currently
going by Sean learns his father is
gunning for him when 10 Rings agents
steal the Jade pendant his mother left
him teaming up with his sister Xiang Chi
finally addresses his issues with his
father by traveling to talo and stopping
winwoo from unleashing the soul-sucking
monster known as the dweller in darkness
on the world before dying to save his
son when Wu grants Xiang Chi the 10
Rings which begins sending signals out
into the universe
while all this is going on one Rogue
Avenger is unknowingly creating her own
brand of Chaos in the small town of West
View New Jersey unable to cope with the
loss of vision who Thanos kills by
ripping the Mind Stone out of his head
Wanda maximoff manifests powerful
reality warping abilities drawing from
her childhood love of American sitcoms
Wanda warps Westview into an idyllic
town where she lives a Suburban life
with a new version of vision she even
gives birth to twin boys who quickly
mature in a single episode to maintain
this illusion Wanda inadvertently mind
controls the real-life citizens of
Westview into becoming her personal
puppets her activities attract the
attention of the new intelligence agency
soared and Agatha Harkness while Wanda
eventually comes to her senses and tries
to free Westview Agatha goads Wanda into
a battle Wanda comes out on top however
and although she has to sacrifice her
happy life with her husband and children
she Embraces her new role as the Scarlet
witch she also takes Agatha's darkhold
and starts dreaming of alternate
realities where her sons are still alive
Wanda's reality warfing abilities also
permanently alter One Woman sword agent
Captain Monica Rambo the adult daughter
of Carol Danvers best friend Maria
Monica attempts to help Wanda with her
grief and is exposed multiple times to
Wanda's hex energies this rewrites
Monica's cells giving her the power to
absorb energy and become intangible
after hearing of her performance in
Westview Nick Fury sends a scroll to ask
Monica to join him on a mission in outer
space with his secret identity now
exposed Peter turns to Doctor Strange
hoping the sorcerer can snap his fingers
and wish his problems away instead
strange offers to cast a spell to make
the world forget Peter Parker is
Spider-Man it seems like an ideal
solution until Peter keeps asking
strange to rewrite the Spell creating
multiple fractures in the Multiverse and
drawing in people who know Peter Parker
is Spider-Man soon Spider-Man villains
from different cinematic universes
including Dr Octopus Sandman the lizard
and Electro begin slipping into the MCU
however the worst new arrival is the
Green Goblin who kills Peter's Aunt May
distraught Peter receives help from an
unexpected Source two Multiverse Peter
Parkers who look a lot like Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire together the
Spider-Man concoct some creative cures
for their enemies and de-power their
shared Rogues Gallery but just as things
seem to be looking up the Multiverse
begins to fracture Peter does the
responsible Thing by asking strange to
make the whole world forget Peter Parker
and prevent the villains from coming
through this essentially makes Peter a
non-entity in the MCU Cuts him off from
his support network of Heroes and
friends and sets him up for a brand new
Trilogy of solo Spider-Man films oh and
Strange's spell also strands the vulture
in Sony's Universe while Sony's Venom
briefly pops up in the MCU as instead of
fighting Spider-Man he spends his entire
visit getting drunk in a Mexican bar and
accidentally gives birth to a new
symbiote whom he unknowingly abandons in
the MCU however not all heroes need to
be alone for the holidays after a now 22
year old Kate Bishop crashes an
underground New York auction and steals
Clint Barton's former Ronin outfit she
draws a lot of unwanted and potentially
lethal attention to herself from the
tracksuit Mafia and Kingpin fortunately
Hawkeye is in town with his family to
see the embarrassingly catchy Rogers the
musical initially hoping to retrieve his
Ronin suit and keep Kate out of trouble
Clint ends up mentoring Kate as they go
up against Maya Lopez AKA Echo Elena
bilova and Kingpin after bonding with
Clans over their shared trauma and
showing she's really good at shooting
people with trick arrows Kate looks like
she'll be taking over the mantle of
Hawkeye and joining the mcu's
ever-expanding roster of new superheroes
a now teenaged America Chavez is pursued
by demonic agents to kill a variant
Doctor Strange America and Strange's
corpse accidentally slip into the
mainstream Marvel Universe our doctor
strange discovers that Wanda maximoff
now corrupted by the darkhold wants to
steal America's Multiverse traveling
Powers so she can live in a world where
her twin sons are alive when strange and
the Sorcerers of kamertage stand in her
way Wanda murders the sorcerers forcing
America and strange to flee to Earth 838
there strange is arrested by this
universe's Illuminati a secret society
that includes alternate versions of
Baron Marto Black Bolt Captain Carter
Captain Marvel professor Charles Xavier
and Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four
believing strange to be the real threat
to the Multiverse the Illuminati failed
to heed Strange's warnings of the
Scarlet Witch this becomes their undoing
when Wanda travels to Earth 838 by
possessing the body of her alternate
self and Slaughters the Illuminati she
then banishes strange to another
alternate world where strange learns his
variant is an arrogant shirt who brought
about the end of his Universe using this
world's darkhold strange possesses the
body of the dead Doctor Strange variant
on his Homeworld and battles Wanda
fortunately America is able to get Wanda
to see the error of her ways by taking
her back to Earth 838 where her sons are
horrified by how evil she's become
filled with remorse Wanda collapses the
structure on Mount wundergore and
destroys the dark old and all realities
before seemingly killing herself
sometime later strange now sporting a
third eye thanks to his use of the dark
old encounters the dark dimensions
sorceress Clea who tells him he started
an incursion in her home reality strange
and clear then leap into the dark
dimension indicating that as the Marvel
Cinematic Universe continues to expand
we won't be dealing with just one
universe but several
across the pond in London mild-mannered
gift shop employee Steven Grant suffers
from regular blackouts and discovers
he's an alternate personality of Mark
Spector the Moon Knight after Mark
suffers a breakdown following the death
of his mother Steven takes over their
body and gets a job at the National Art
Gallery despite being mistreated by his
co-workers Steven maintains his positive
outlook and tries to live a peaceful
life this life is thrown into chaos when
Arthur Harrow a former Avatar of konshu
resurfaces as the new Avatar of Ahmet
the Egyptian goddess of divine
retribution hoping to preemptively stop
all evil by destroying everyone before
they get a chance to perform a wicked
act Harrow and his cult free Ahmet and
send people to their deaths before their
time to stop him Stephen and Mark team
up with Layla who acquires superpowers
of her own by becoming the Avatar of the
goddess tawaret and managed to imprison
Amit in Hero's mortal form although
Stephen manages to broker a deal with
konshu to release Mark and him from the
Moon Gods service he doesn't realize
that Mark has a third personality the
homicidal Jake lockley who's still
killing people for konsho
after months of adventuring with the
Guardians of the Galaxy Thor has
recovered from the crippling depression
for failing to prevent thanos's snap he
learns the terrifying Gore the god
butcher has been slaughtering Gods
across the cosmos with his Ultra
powerful necrosort with the help of King
Valkyrie and a new female Thor revealed
to be Thor's ex-girlfriend Jane Foster
Thor defeats Gore but not without cost
Foster dies and travels to the Norse
afterlife of Valhalla following her
wishes Thor takes in Gore's super
powered daughter who goes by the name
love
Thor's actions have earned him new
mortal enemies in the Greek God Zeus and
his son Hercules who vow revenge on Thor
and the rest of Earth's heroes in New
Jersey a Young Avengers super fan named
Kamala Khan finds herself in a
generation's old feud between an
organization of Pakistani protectors
known as the order of the red daggers
and a group of interdimensional Invaders
known as the clandestines Kamala
discovers that she is a descendant of
the clandestines and therefore a
super-powered mutant hybrid with help of
her friends and through a series of
trials that allow her to master her
Newfound Powers Kamala expels the
invading clandestines and saves Earth in
the process settling on the moniker Miss
Marvel meanwhile the superhero Community
continues to grow after a car accident
causes Attorney Jennifer Walters to
absorb the gamma-irradiated blood of her
cousin Bruce Banner she becomes a Hulk
herself instead of fighting crime
through vigilantism Walters elects to
use her new Insider perspective to
represent super beings in court who the
hell are you Jennifer Walters and
attorney at law working with the law
firm of glknh in Los Angeles She-Hulk
handles cases involving the Abomination
Wong Titania and More in wakanda King
t'challa contracts a mysterious disease
and becomes terminally ill shuri
attempts to save his life by
constructing an artificial heart-shaped
herb to replace the ones Eric killmonger
destroyed however she doesn't have
enough time and t'challa dies
over in Cambridge Massachusetts team
Prodigy Riri Williams runs a private
business doing her classmates homework
for money she uses the cash to fund her
own private projects including an Iron
Man style armored suit one of her
designs a vibranium detector she created
for her Metallurgy class is appropriated
by the CIA which uses it to seek out
vibranium deposits on Earth
unfortunately this allows them to
uncover the underwater Kingdom of
Telecom placing the United States in
conflict with namor's people Namor
approaches Queen ramonda and shuri in
wakanda and shows them the vibranium
detector telling them he wants the
scientist who built it concerned shuri
and Okoye travel to MIT to warn Riri but
both Riri and shuri are then taken
prisoner by the telekinil Namor proposes
an alliance between wakanda and telecon
but when shuri and Riri Escape Namor
attacks wakanda and queen raimonda is
killed using a telecon plant to recreate
the heart shaped herb shuri becomes the
New Black Panther and leads wakanda
against the attacking forces
we cannot let it consume our people
although she craves Vengeance she
chooses to show Neymar mercy and
establish a peaceful alliance between
their two nations in the aftermath shuri
is able to let go of her guilt over her
brother's death and is introduced to
nakia's son Tucson or as the wakandans
will come to know him Prince t'challa
back on Earth Scott Lang attempts to
retire from superheroics while promoting
his Memoir look out for the little guy
this upsets his daughter Cassie who
feels the world still needs Heroes she
invents a Quantum satellite which can
send signals to the quantum realm and
learn if people in the subatomic World
need help while testing it the signal
gets hijacked and Scott Cassie Hank
Janet and hope are sucked through a
portal into the quantum realm in the
quantum realm Janet comes face to face
with her past when she learns Kang has
turned the realm into his totalitarian
Kingdom Scott and Cassie are captured by
the ruler and reunite with Darren cross
now Kang's delusional minion Modoc after
Kang forces Anthony man to steal back
his power core so he can exit the
quantum realm Cassie escapes and teams
up with a group of rebels to lead an
uprising against the evil Tyrant they're
aided by Janet Hope Hank a reformed
Modoc and Hank's team of hyper-evolved
ants in the end hope helps Scott destroy
both the power core and Kang before they
return to Earth however this isn't the
end of Kang as variants are now emerging
from all over the Multiverse
out in space Peter Quill is in a deep
depression after losing Gamora and
seeing her alternate variants depart for
places unknown wanting to help her
brother with his grief mantis teams up
with Drax to travel to earth and get
Peter a special Christmas gift Footloose
actor Kevin Bacon while Star-Lord is
horrified by the kidnapping bacon
chooses to celebrate Christmas with
guardians after hearing how his films
inspired Peter to save the universe by
dancing mantis later tells Peter of
their shared parentage reminding him
that he still has family in the Stars
things take a darker turn when the
sovereign's New Creation Adam Warlock
attacks nowhere and critically injures
rocket after learning the high
evolutionary installed a kill switch in
Rockets cybernetic implants to stop
anyone from treating him the team
travels to the high evolutionaries
Planet counter Earth to save their
friend in the process they reunite with
Gamora who has joined the ravagers
together the Guardians of the Galaxy
save rocket and defeat the high
evolutionary in the aftermath Peter
returns to Earth to be with his
grandfather Gamora goes back to the
ravagers Mantis embarks on a voyage of
self-discovery and Drax and nebula turn
nowhere into a sanctuary for displaced
people in races this leaves rocket now
the captain of the Guardians to build a
new team consisting of an adult Groot
the ravager craiglinn cosmo the space
dog High evolutionary experiment phyla
and a reformed Adam Warlock
thank you
[Music]